People, I believe are good.
People are good per se.
They want to do good things.
However, sometimes it's not easy
to do good things.
Sometimes you want to, I don't know,
you want to plant a tree
but where, how, with who?
How are you going to do it?
And like this, like so many other
initiatives, so many other things
that you might want to do,
and it's difficult.
So, what we want to do is
to make it super easy.
We don't want any excuses
from businesses.
If you want to do good,
tell us how and we will help you.
Marc Cirera, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm very good, thank you.
It's still covid-19.
We have the distance for you
and a beautiful Paramount hotel in Dubai.
And Marc, you are an entrepreneur.
But you're originally from Barcelona,
but here you are in Dubai.
And I can't wait to talk to you
a little bit about doing good
for the world
and helping companies do good.
So, tell me a little bit about yourself.
And what are you doing here in Dubai?
Sure.
So, well, I started doing business.
And then at some point, I realized that
I needed something
a bit more meaningful in my life.
I wanted to make a larger impact
than just making money
for the sake of it.
And so at that point,
I went to Australia
to do a masters in business ethics.
And that really kind of motivated me
to get into this sector
of sustainability, CSR, business ethics.
To help businesses make money
while doing good.
Right.
But you're originally not from Dubai.
You're still from Barcelona
and you spent some time in Australia,
what brought you to Dubai?
Correct. Love brought me here.
So, before coming here,
I was in London.
I was working there as a CSR consultant.
Then I quit my job.
I left the city,
just was looking for new experiences.
And I went to South America to travel.
And while there,
I met the love of my life,
who she was working here at the time.
And I just followed her here
and here I am now.
Beautiful.
And you're raising a family here.
Marc, you're an entrepreneur.
You are a different kind of entrepreneur
because your focus is not just
on taking a business
and growing it exponentially.
Not the regular hockey stick.
But your focus is on doing things
that do good for the environment
and do good for the world
while helping other companies do that.
Tell me a little bit about,
why you're even in this doing good space?
Yes.
So, normally, I don't call myself
an entrepreneur,
I call myself a social entrepreneur.
Because for me,
just to starting a business
without having this element
of giving back to society,
it was not really meaningful.
So, whenever I thought
about creating something,
it was always with this
purpose driven kind of goal.
And so, I created Companies for Good,
which is a social enterprise
and we help businesses do good.
And as you were saying,
it's not the typical, I would say,
startup in the sense
that we're not really looking
at growing fast and raising funds
and making it huge.
We're just looking at doing things well
and enjoying the journey as well,
which I think is super important.
I've seen lots of entrepreneurs
suffer a lot
while creating their startups.
And I'm sure you are a witness
of having told with so many people
of how tough the journey can be, right?
And how people sometimes
are always looking for funds
or they are like struggling to
to make things happen.
And so, for me,
that was something very important.
I set three big objectives
when setting up Companies for Good.
One was to make it profitable,
to make money.
One was to make a positive impact
on society and the planet.
And the third one was to have
a good life while doing it.
Good, work, life balance.
So, these were the three
kind of elements
of the startup.
Right.
I think that's a very interesting trend
that we see today.
Unlike a lot of different timelines
in the world,
but now we have social entrepreneurs
that are realizing that
it's not just about, you know,
doing non-profitable work
and just volunteering their time.
But you have to make it
also, a profitable business.
You have to make
a positive social contribution
to the world
while also having a profitable startup
that can actually generate revenue
and keep sustaining.
Because if you want to make an impact
and I remember I read a quote,
one that really transform me,
if you make an impact
on a billion people,
you also make a billion dollars.
They go hand in hand.
It's not just about doing good.
But it has to be a two way street.
Because it also, you have
to have a good team
that is working on you.
You have to attract
the best talent to work for this.
So, I think that's very inspiring.
Marc, before we go
into Companies for Good more,
I'd love for you to tell me
a little bit about
your experience here in Dubai.
What have you observed in the ecosystem?
You've worked with different companies,
you've seen different VCs and incubators,
what is happening here in Dubai?
There are lots of things happening.
I've seen the startup scene
change a lot in the past five years.
There are so many accelerator programs,
incubators, and generally, like
the ecosystem is growing a lot.
I think it's an amazing place
to start up anything,
any project, any business.
It's a place full of opportunities here.
And so, and it's fairly easy as well
in terms of bureaucracy.
I mean, it's fairly easy
to set up your business
and start operating
and start the invoicing
and start working
within almost hours, sometimes.
That's pretty crazy because
you've had also different experiences
with bureaucracy.
And you've observed different countries
in how they operate.
So, how is that different?
Yes, it's absolutely different.
Before having Companies for Good here,
I had the business back home,
which is Barcelona.
And over there,
the bureaucracy is a nightmare.
It's like, it's so complicated
to set up a business.
It's so costly.
Even before you start operating
you really need to pay
lots of taxes
and you need to pay fees.
And it takes days, if not months
to be able to start working
and start doing something.
And that's really not good
for the entrepreneurs and of ecosystem.
What we need, we are young people
or not so young,
but with lots of ideas
we want to make things happen.
And if the institutions
keep putting all these barriers,
then they're just making things
way more difficult.
Right.
So, tell me a little bit
about what's happening with the world.
And, you know,
you're coming in and saying,
you know, we have all these
great organizations that are looking to
have these bonding group experiences,
but while also making
a positive impact on the world.
What is happening to the world
where companies are having this shift,
where they're looking
to have these impactful projects
that you've observed which triggered
you are doing Companies for Good?
Yeah, I think two things are happening.
One is that,
people are more aware nowadays
about things that are not
really going as we would like to
in the world
in terms of like climate change, right?
It's on the agenda of all governments.
Everybody's talking about it.
In terms of social inequalities,
diversity and inclusion.
There are so many things
that perhaps, in the 70s, 80s,
businesses could just carry on
and people are looking the other way.
But now, it's not happening anymore.
Everybody is way more accountable.
And businesses also,
are more like aware
that they need to do more things.
The other one is that,
people, I believe are good.
People, are good per se.
They want to do good things.
However, sometimes it's not easy
to do good things.
Sometimes you want to, I don't know,
you want to plant a tree
but where, how?
With who?
How are you going to do it?
And like these,
like so many other initiatives,
so many other things
that you might want to do
and it's difficult.
So, what we want to do
is to make it super easy.
We don't want any excuses
from businesses.
If you want to do good,
tell us how and we will help you.
So, that's why we're seeing
that people really, and people
and when I mean people,
I mean companies are made by people.
So, when I talk about companies,
I always think about
the people making up those companies.
Because I think it happens a lot
that people talk about,
"Oh, Microsoft is this and that."
or I don't know,
that oil company or coca cola, or this.
Sorry, I'm dropping names here.
But these are worldwide.
And who are these brands?
Like I mean, they're just legal names.
And behind those names
there are lots of people.
And lots of different people
who care about different things,
who have families
who live within the planet.
And so, it's those people
that we're talking to
when we are offering
our support to them in the sense of,
how do you want
to make a positive contribution
with your colleagues in this case?
Do you guys want to do something
for the refugee community?
You want to do something for
those who are suffering cancer?
Do you want to support children?
Do you want to protect the environment?
So, we know that people care
about those things
and we just give them
the opportunity to do something about it.
So, what it sounds to me
is that you've identified a gap
between a desire that people want.
So, like in economics,
I think the supply and demand,
there's a lot of demand,
there's not really supply
because people might know
that they want to do certain things
but they have no idea
as to how they are going to go do it.
How do I plant a tree?
How do I help families
that are in need?
Right?
And so, you're creating this platform
where you're helping bridge that gap
and saying,
"You want to do good?
I know how to do the good,
and I can just help you leverage
the human capital and financial capital
to go and do that."
Give me a broad spectrum
of what types of activities
do you actually do?
And how do you go
about taking companies
and make them happen?
So, in terms of activities,
we have many different ones.
We categorize them between
doing good for the environment
or doing good for the communities.
For the environment,
we do beach cleanups,
we do a tree planting,
we do forest reforestation,
we do under water clean up
with divers on the ocean,
we do clean ups on the desert.
So, we do many different actions
that are about keeping our planet clean
and trying to keep the air
as healthy and possible in terms of like
offsetting CO2 emissions.
And then for the communities,
we have activities to support children,
to support people of determination,
which are like people with special needs.
Here, we call them
people of determination.
And with their groups of employees
to go to a center where there are like
children with special needs
and they teach them,
they play with them,
they read books to them, etc.
We have activities to support refugees,
people that are suffering from cancer.
So, many different initiatives
that you can do something
with your colleagues,
and that has a positive impact
on that certain community demanded.
Right.
So, what's been the most
both easiest and hardest part
of this journey?
Because I imagine that
every company that you work with,
it's a different challenge,
it's a different flow.
But over you know, you mentioned that
you're doing hundreds of projects.
What's the pattern
of the easiest and the hardest things
that you've had to overcome?
The easiest is to make people happy.
People love doing these things.
And I cannot repeat it enough times.
When we start one of our activities,
everybody arrives, they're be like,
not grumpy, but their level of energy
is not that high.
Some for instance,
let's imagine a beach cleanup. Right?
We say to a company there,
that group of employees
that are coming like, we meet at 9 AM
and we will start.
They arrive at 9 AM
and either sleepy like,
often they don't know their colleagues
or they don't know them much.
Because in the office,
the kind of relationships established
with people might be different
from outside the office, right?
In the office there are lots of hierarchies
or your day to day work,
wherever that is.
So, people don't talk much
among themselves.
They're not really like laughing,
not really engaged.
Time keeps passing,
they keep doing things together.
And then by 11, 12,
when they finish the activity,
they are such a hype there.
The level of energy is huge.
People are laughing.
They're talking on each other much more.
And we ask them afterwards,
you know, like,
"Have you met anyone new?"
"Yeah. We met lots of colleagues
I didn't know."
And they love doing a clean up.
For some people,
only the idea of picking up trash
might be a bit like, I don't know,
there people who work on that.
Why do I need to go and clean up?
But once you're there
and you see that real impact
you are making on nature,
something happens,
something quite magic
that it lifts you up.
They call it "the giver's glow" as well.
It's a bit like, I don't know,
you feel fulfilled, you feel happy,
you feel you've done something good.
And we see that all the time
with the groups that we're taking
to do these kind of activities.
That they end up super excited.
That they end up
obviously much more aware
of the situation,
whether it's environment
or the community.
But it's that feeling
that people have that,
wow, we've done something good.
We've done it together
and that's exciting.
That's really good.
Now, moving a little bit more
to the business side of things.
Because that's always something
that I'm very curious about.
How do you get companies
to know who you are
and to understand the value
of Companies for Good?
Because it's not every day
that a company wakes up and says,
"Maybe I should take my team
to a beach cleanup today.
Oh, and by the way,
there is this Marc
from Companies For Good."
So, how does this whole cycle work?
You know, you would be surprised
that there are many people
that wake up one day and say,
"Oh, I want to do something
with my team."
There are loads of them.
And we're not talking about like the CEO
or the vice president of a company.
We're talking about a team leader.
It could be the head of HR
and you have a team
of seven people under you,
or the head of finance or,
and these people,
it's not their area of expertise, right,
to organize activities.
They have other
kind of day to day jobs to do.
And normally, they want to do something
a bit original.
Something a bit meaningful.
And perhaps they heard
about the escape rooms,
go karting or some similar activities.
They want to do something
like a bit more impactful.
And they don't know,
Right.
They don't know what to do
or what they could do.
And so,
when they found that,
when they find us,
they're really excited.
We had, I think, a very rare position
in the market since the beginning,
which I think we're very blessed about,
which is the clients are happy
when they found us.
We haven't done any
like outreach, any sales.
We've been of course,
we've done like some marketing
and we try to position ourselves
in Google, in the rankings.
It's not that we've been
just sitting and people like, we work.
One of actually interesting things
that you mentioned was that,
you know, this is a pretty niche market.
People don't often search
for beach cleanup
or planting trees on Google.
And that's one of the ways
you've reached to your client base right?
Yes. That's helped us a lot,
that we are in a niche market.
And so, we've done a little bit
of search engine optimization
on our website
and a little bit of link building
and writing blogs, etc.
So, when people wanted to find us,
it would be easier.
And so in Google,
we rank quite well because of that,
because it's fairly niche
and we've done an effort.
But also like we were working
with lots of businesses that come to us
because of word of mouth.
So, they ask around, like,
"What can we do to do an activity
that gives back to society
or to that helps the environment?"
And then after having
a couple of conversations,
they're like, "Oh, you know,
you should contact Companies for Good.
They organize these kind of things."
But as I was saying,
like since the beginning,
I was shocked when the phone would ring
and it would be,
I work for DHL.
I work for Killens, I work for HSBC,
I work for Amazon, and I'm like,
"Okay.  And so how can I help you?"
"Oh, we heard you do a tree planting,
or this kind of activity like."
"Yeah, we can help."
"Oh yes please.
That would be amazing.
Because I've been looking for it."
I'm like, "Okay, sure."
"Can we do it next week?"
"Yes, sure."
"This is the price."
"Okay, fine."
So, it's been surprisingly,
I wouldn't say easy because
easy is a undermining word
because we worked hard for it.
But it's been a pleasant journey,
let's put it this way.
That's incredible.
What's next? What's the vision
for Companies for Good?
Well, that's a very good
a very good question.
What we have done a lot
this year is go digital.
Yeah.
Like everyone else. Right?
It's no news.
But all our activities
were physical team activities
with teams.
Corona came and we had
to cancel every single activity.
In Feb, we did, I don't know,
about 20 activities.
We had more than 20 booked for March.
It was our best month ever.
We were like growing a lot.
It was amazing.
Everything was like fantastic,
and then boom.
So, from one week to another,
everything got canceled.
And we were like,
okay, is this going to last
like one month or like one year,
ten years, who knows.
But we quickly,
like reinvented ourselves.
And while the situation was,
you know, tough in terms
of physical team activities,
we started to create online things.
And so, now we have a very cool
team building activity called,
the climate change challenge.
And this is like hundreds of people
can play online.
Normally they do it like
in teams of a company.
And it's a group of eco heroes.
They travel around the world
and they go to different continents,
discovering what is
the climate change issue
that is affecting the most in that area.
They need to overcome
different challenges and games
and they keep moving on like
some kind of competing among teams,
but learning at the same time
and having having some fun.
And that's been kind of a positive thing
from these challenging year.
And I think, in terms of the vision
that's where we want to go more,
because physical team activities
are fantastic
and it creates this kind of hype.
But it's a bit more limited in terms of,
where you can do it.
And we also have many businesses
that are international, right.
And so they have an office here,
but they also have an office in Oman,
another one in Saudi
another one in Qatar or elsewhere.
And often, they want to do activities
among their teams
to bring them together
but cross-border.
And how can you do that? Online.
Right.
So, what are some nuggets of advice
you can provide for some
young social entrepreneurs
that are on their journey?
Obviously, it's a very different type
of journey than the average entrepreneur
that is just trying to raise money
for a first startup that is
on the hockey stick trajectory.
What should young entrepreneurs
need to know as they're embarking
on this social adventure?
I think two things
are very, very important.
And one is give,
offer to your customers
what they might want or need.
Not what you like or what you think
they might need like.
I've seen so many
both normal entrepreneurs
or social entrepreneurs,
I don't know why I'm calling them normal,
but whatever,
like non-social entrepreneurs
and social entrepreneurs that
they're so passionate about their idea
and what they want to do
that they have missed
on checking with their customers,
their clients,
if that's what they want
or how they want it.
And they spent a year working
on that product or service,
hidden in a room or something,
investing a lot of money,
even like spending
a lot of time thinking
about the name or the logo.
And then, once they go out there
after a year,
obviously they have no money
and almost no energy
because they are working so hard.
And then often they find
that the customers want something else
or that they want it differently.
And so, it's a very, very
kind of clashing situation.
Whereas, I always tell people, you know,
"Whenever you have a little tiny thing,
go out there. Go out there.
Start operating, start learning."
And that worked for me very well because
when I started Companies for Good,
I went out there
without having a business license,
like the website it was made by me,
and I have no idea
how to make websites.
One of these like premade things.
The logo was made by a friend
and it was a disaster logo.
So, I mean, but so what?
And we started learning.
And we started already engaging
with customers.
Some customers like some of the ideas
and they already started doing activities
which helped us finance
our next steps and so on.
So, it's been,
I think a growth journey
and a smooth journey because of this
kind of action driven attitude
of let's get out there
and let's start working
and then we will be polishing
and improving things as we go.
Wow.
So, that's definitely
one piece of advice.
And the other one is obviously
like believing what you do.
Be passionate about it.
Because there are so many bumps
on the journey,
so many difficulties that unless
you like what you're doing
and you believe in it,
you're not going to enjoy it.
And what's the point of setting up
a business if you don't enjoy it?
Right.
100%.
Marc, I want to thank you
for being so gracious with your time.
You know, this is one of few
that we managed to do in person.
And I'm happy that we're able to do this
in a social distancing context
and here in Dubai.
But before we leave,
I have to put you on the spot
for one last question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or your wife would use
to describe you
or any of the companies
that you got to work with.
Wow. Three words.
Maybe I would say action driven person.
Action driven person.
Yeah. I make things happen.
I love that.
Marc, thank you very, very much.
Stay safe, stay healthy.
And continue doing good
for the world, literally,
and helping a lot of other companies.
And I'm sure, by the way,
that it's not just limited
to that event
when they come to work with you,
but it's a ripple effect.
They take it then into their home,
to their colleagues,
they tell their families,
and it's creating
a butterfly effect where
it's the network effects is exponential.
And from the team that you work
it just ricochets.
So, thank you very, very much.
Thank you so much.